so the video you shot
that went viral it's there's been a lot
of videos that have been similar to that
video since it came out
yeah yeah yeah i remember specifically
when the baby put out his video what
song was it the baby he did it for
the rockstar the rockstar remix yeah
yeah we needed the black black lives
matter remix yeah
and um very similar
almost to the t yeah um
how did you feel when you saw that i
think now because
i think the baby was like the last
person that's done it right well yeah
because there were some other
there were some other artists similar
yeah yeah yeah yeah
but uh long story short the baby didn't
i i
kind of felt like yo i'm here to inspire
i can't be mad when i inspire somebody
you know and i may not even have
inspired the baby i may have inspired
his
his director or his team yeah we were
talking about that i was like i'm not
sure the baby like saw that and was like
let's do that it might have been
a subconscious effort on his director or
whoever his videographer was
because it was it was like damn yeah but
then again i put out that video
back in 2017 who's to say that his
director had that in his subconscious
and didn't even remember
like how did he how he got there yeah
you know so like like i said like
he was telling the story and if if your
director is getting inspired to tell a
story
something similar to what i did you know
pushing him pushing the same message
i was gonna say like did did you um
any sort of communication with him or
his camp at all about it no i i had
tweeted
i was like yo this looks very familiar
and i was it that tweet kind of went up
got a bunch of like replies and uh re
tweets and [ __ ] like that so
that was it but i didn't i didn't reach
out to nobody it ain't
it's not my business you know what i'm
saying i got i got my bag i got my deal
off that video
so it's like if you want to eat too go
ahead you know i'm still eating off that
song so it's like yeah when you when
your videos are so
like uh con conceptually so dope like
is it it's like is it hard to like out
like like
when you shoot videos like that that are
so
conceptually at a high level like
can it be frustrating to just shoot a
regular video or just like every v
like i feel like you you like you gotta
i don't know outdo yourself but like
that [ __ ] you know you got some crazy
visuals bro i think
i write i write songs visually so i see
the video first video as i'm right while
you're writing it literally
like when i just was doing the freestyle
i had my eyes closed i literally
literally visually see what i'm saying
so a lot of times it's not hard to come
up with these
conceptual videos it's hard to execute
them sometimes because sometimes
i did so grand and now being independent
you ain't got capital that's going to
spend 50 000 on the video you know
like you got to come out of pocket so
yeah i literally visually write every
song
every video i don't know if a lot of
people know but like like i directed and
wrote those treatments for all those
people well you said you shot the
that video you're yourself right yeah
yeah yeah literally
actually it's crazy on the on i just put
the camera on the floor
that was kool-aid and cornstarch the
blood was the blood
stuff yeah bro i spent seven dollars on
that video and that video changed my
life that's [ __ ] crazy
artists out there don't make no [ __ ]
excuses about what you should be doing
because you can make the [ __ ] happen ah
dirt cheap